hello things need to be shot no captain  Flint killed everyone in Liseberg I see  no reason that wild bull Iman should  lollygag about the place disrespecting  the memories of the former townsville if  you could clear the town of them that  would be most gentlemanly the objectives  on your HUD pertain to your active  mission you can change your active  mission by using the mission block and  your active device  I'm out  you  that's one area free of HollyMoms this  would be an even greater achievement if  anyone in liseberg was still allowed to  celebrate your victory but still well  done  house efficacious one amongst will think  twice about raiding peaceful cities in  the future hopefully